alexis poulain bonjour bonjour heureux
de vous retrouver dans la matinale de
rtl france alors ce soir emmanuel macron
reprend donc la parole sur le coco vide
à quoi est ce qu'on peut s'attendre
et bien comme d'habitude c'est le retour
des conseils de défense des prises de
parole du président emmanuel macron
pensais je pense avoir mis le coc vite
derrière lui être enfin tranquille passé
dans la réouverture la relance
économique mais voilà le variant delta
ril et patatras il faut revenir à
nouveau sur des annonces sanitaires et
on le voit les français sont fatigués
alors qu'on peut s'attendre déjà la
question de la vaccination obligatoire
pour certaines professions évidemment
c'est les soignants qui sont encore une
fois en ligne de mire ce qu'on
applaudissait il ya de ça un an sont
maintenant montré du doigt comme
réfractaires au vaccin il faut
absolument les vacciner mais qu'en est
il des autres métiers de contact ce soit
les pompiers la police ou ou bien
d'autres métiers encore professeur là
reste à savoir quel sera le choix des
monnaies de mâcon et puis on voit que il
y à un tir de barrage de personnalités
politiques que ce soit bernard kouchner
françois bayrou qui voudraient même
rendre le vaccin obligatoire pour tous
et faire fi finalement de du choix
personnel d'une obligation vaccinale
sachant que l'autorisation de mise sur
le marché court encore jusque en
quelques années je crois 2023 que nous
sommes encore en phase test même si les
vaccins ont déjà un peu de recul donc il
ya vraiment beaucoup de questions sur
l'obligation vaccinale bien sûr sur des
mesures encore de restriction de
couvre-feu ou bien de deux passes
sanitaire est ce que le pastel terre va
rentrer dans la vie quotidienne pour
aller au théâtre au cinéma au restaurant
est ce qu'on va voir des jauges diminuer
ce serait calamiteux évidemment d'avoir
de ce type d'annoncé parce que on voit
bien que les français veulent retrouver
une vie normale certes mais avec autant
de barrières ça risque de compliquer les
choses pour exemple la foire de tours
qui avait mis en place un pass sanitaire
qui a été refusé un parent à la fois les
exposants et les gens qui voulaient se
rendre à cette fois donc il peut y avoir
là un risque de refus de désobéissance
civile massive face à ce passe sanitaire
qui est vu comme encore attentatoires
aux libertés avec un conseil
constitutionnel qui jusqu'à présent n'a
pas trop censurer les mesures mises en
place dans cette crise sanitaire mesures
d'exception donc on peut s'attendre
malheureusement à de nouvelles
d'exception et vous le lisiez alexis les
français fatigué de ces annonces oui on
le voyait dans votre micro trottoir
entre ceux qui ne peuvent plus écouter
regarder mâcon par fatigue ceux qui ne
veulent pas ceux qui veulent passer à
autre chose
on voit bien que il ya là quelque chose
qui ne fonctionne plus dans le narratif
qu'ovide le fait de dire que le delta
arrivé qu'on recommence à zéro pour
préparer une rentrée avec toujours un
ces chiffres exponentielle parce que le
virus est plus contagieux mais qu'en est
il de la mortalité du virus
non nous n'avons pas les chiffres on
parle maintenant de contamination on ne
parle plus vraiment du nez nombre de
gens en réanimation aussi des capacités
de service réanimation
parce que le problème reste le même
depuis un an de crise sanitaire
l'exécutif n'a pas préparé le système de
santé à lutter contre ces vagues
successives de coronavirus nous manquons
toujours de moyens en france même si on
peut se targuer d'avoir un superbe
système de santé donc la solution la
moins chère finalement c'est la
vaccination
d'où cette poussée communicationnel sur
la vaccination parce que nous devons
aller plus loin mais encore une fois
aujourd'hui l'union européenne dit avoir
suffisamment de doses pour vacciner 70 %
de la population adulte en france nous
sommes à 40 % de la population vaccinée
donc pourquoi rendre obligatoire à
vaccins dont nous n'avons pas
visiblement assez de doses pour vacciner
100 % de la population à partir de 12
ans puisque maintenant il est question
de vacciner dès 12 ans donc voilà un peu
le je pense la fatigue des français qui
veulent simplement retrouver une vie
normale qu'ovide ou pas avec aussi la
liberté de choix bien sûr la liberté de
conscience sur l'obligation vaccinale ou
non sur l'utilisation ou non d'un pass
vaccinale sachant que on voit bien que
la gestion sanitaire depuis le début a
été très sécuritaire et peu sanitaires
vu le manque de moyens criant toujours
le même au sein des personnels soignants
au sein des hôpitaux et alexis un échec
à éviter pour en marche le fiasco vide
évidemment pour en marche surtout pour
emmanuel macron parce que c'est lui qui
a vraiment personnaliser la gestion de
cette crise sanitaire avec ses conseils
de défense où il était seul à décider
entouré d'un aréopage d'experts qui lui
souffler à l'oreille ce qu'il fallait
faire mais au final c'est lui qui sera
responsable soit des nouvelles mesures
de restriction de liberté
d'une vaccination obligatoire ou non
soit d'une crise qui n'en finit pas
celle du co vide on voit bien qu'il a à
l'issue du très mauvais résultats des
régionales gardéens l'exécutif tel qu'il
est malgré la mise en examen d'un
ministre de la justice malgré les
résultats calamiteux de ses ministres
dans les urnes il veut garder olivier
ferrand il veut garder jean castex
jusqu'au bout de cette crise qu vite
parce que c'est le dernier joker
finalement qui lui reste après ce sera
lui qui sera monté de noël c'est déjà le
cas il a vraiment une hyper
personnaliser cette gestion de crise
donc aujourd'hui c'est encore lui qui
prend la parole à quelques jours du 14
juillet où là il avait prévu une
allocution de renouveau de nouveaux
mondes de re départ et les gens sont
obligés de changer son discours
évidemment et il prépare déjà le
changement de ce discours avec cette
allocution ce soir basée sur la santé et
n'oublie pas bien sûr en toile de fond
les réformes celle qu'il veut faire
passer avant la fin de son quinquennat
assurance chômage et retraite et là
évidemment on en parle moins puisque le
delta prend toute la lumière
merci beaucoup alexis l'édito politique
d'alexis poulain à revoir sur les
réseaux sociaux